this video is brought to you by bespoke
post bespoke post is a monthly
membership club delivering amazing boxes
of top shelf goods from under the radar
brands every month bespoke post
introduces its members to cool new
products outdoor gear bar wear home and
kitchen goods clothing then a lot more
this is all based on a preference quiz
that they fill out it's free to join and
you can skip a month anytime this is one
example of the things they send out in
their boxes this was from the weekender
box and it is a just pull back a little
bit here it's a fantastic weekend bag
made out of this great canvas material
reinforced it's got this metal in here
just feels very very strong very very
good each box has about 70 dollars in
retail value because it's only 45 and
you can preview the box before it ships
out and decide if you want to keep it
swap it or skip the month for no charge
bespoke box lineup is constantly
changing every month and it's great for
you but also a great gift too this was
the brew box can you guys see this beer
making kit obviously says it right there
on the front makes a nice ipa everything
you need is in the box there's all of
the uh what is beer made from
i don't even know uh then this giant
glass bottle there's all the tubing
there's a whole bunch of stuff in there
that you will need right now you guys
can get 20 off your first box by going
to bspk dot me forward slash biographics
20 or just clicking the link in the
description below and entering
biographics 20 at checkout and now
today's video
new york assistant district attorney
abraham rock described fritz duken as
one most desperate and daring criminals
we've ever had here his adventures read
like a romance daily mail to cry to ken
as a notorious scoundrel wanted for
murder on the high seas the sinking and
burning of british ships the burning of
military stores warehouses coaling
stations conspiracy the falsification of
admiralty documents and that's just the
cliff notes version de ken started off
as a big game hunter in africa then he
became a commando during the bar war
responsible for countless assassinations
that earned in the moniker of the black
panther of the beld then in the first
world war he turned saboteur responsible
for the bombing of several ships and
finally in world war ii he established
powerful spyring to help out nazi
germany he did all this to torment great
britain to put it simply there was
nothing that taken would not do in order
to persecute the british find out what
motivated his undying hatred as we take
a look at the life of a man whose
exploits read like something plucked out
of the pages of a pulp magazine this is
the story of the south african
adventurer fritz de ken
[Music]
frederick fritz zhuber ducan was born on
september 21 1877 in east london not the
one in england but rather the city on
the southeastern coast of south africa
it was located in what was back then a
self-governing british colony called
cape colony his parents abraham ducan
and minaju bear were bowers referring to
south africans descended from european
settlers in their case both had french
huguenot ancestry fritz said that his
mother was related to piet jubei the
commandant general of the south african
republic and a war hero to the boers but
then again fritz said a lot of things
throughout his life the man spent
decades in numerous careers using dozens
of fake identities and making countless
incredible and unsubstantiated claims
knowing exactly which ones were true and
which ones were false became an almost
impossible task that not even his
biographers could pull off anyway when
fritz was young his family moved to
nielstron today the town of moromol in
south africa where they purchased a farm
this was in the south african republic
which at the time was an independent
state the household consisted of fritz
his parents his two younger siblings
isbet and pedro and their great uncle
yarn abraham de ken worked as a farmer
hunter and trader and took fritz along
on hunting trips from an early age
teaching him valuable survival and
killing skills out in the african veil
when he was only 12 years old fritz
killed his first man in self-defense the
family used the main room of their house
as a trading post and one day while
abraham was away a zulu customer got
into an argument with fritz's mom over
the prices when he became violent prince
rushed him grabbed the man's zatagai
spear and stabbed him through the
stomach the following year 13 year old
fritz went to school in england he
studied civil engineering after
graduation and joined up with a con man
named christian devries and started
traveling around the world swindling
people from town to town his father
found out about this and put a stop to
it when he finally caught up with fritz
in singapore the young man spent a few
more carefree years just lounging around
europe but the easy times would soon end
forever in 1899 the 21 year old had to
return to his home in south africa where
he developed his fanatical hatred of the
british that would dominate the rest of
his life
[Music]
in 1899 the second bear war erupted
between the united kingdom and two
independent bow estates called the south
african republic and the orange free
state ostensibly the causes for the war
were varied and complex as the conflict
had been brewing for almost a century
but realistically it all boiled down to
gold and diamonds the boers had them
and the british wanted them as you could
tell from the name there was also a
first burr war back in 1880 however that
was a relatively quick affair that
lasted only three months resulting in a
boer victory with only a few hundred
casualties by comparison the second boer
war was longer and much much more brutal
as the british employed scorched earth
policies and concentration camps to
counter the guerrilla warfare used by
the boers although decan had made
england his adopted home he did not
hesitate to return and fight for the
south african republic soon after
joining the war he took part in the
siege of lady smith in november 1899
where he received a gunshot wound to the
shoulder followed by a promotion to
artillery captain the injury couldn't
keep down for long though and by
december he had healed enough to fight
in the battle of calenso where he was
taken prisoner for the first time this
did not prove to be much of an obstacle
for decan as he turned out to be a
master escape artist pw camps could
hardly contain him and he was captured
several times but he always managed to
get away during a return trip to the
farm where he grew up tiken discovered
the gruesome fate that befell his family
at the hands of the british army the
whole place had been burned to the
ground his sister had been raped and
shot in the back his uncle left a hang
from a telegraph pole and his mother had
been kidnapped and sent to a
concentration camp this was the pivotal
moment that changed his life forever the
moment that fritz de ken decided to
spend the rest of his years inflicting
as much pain and as much suffering as
possible on great britain and its people
his greatest hatred was reserved for
general herbert kitchener who was the
commander-in-chief of the british forces
in the burr war and was the one who
enacted the ruthless scorched earth
policy decline discovered that his
survival skills made it perfect for
guerrilla warfare and soon enough he was
leading his own commando unit
responsible for a great deal of sabotage
explosions and stealthy assassinations
his ability to strike without being seen
earned ken the nickname the black
panther of the veld and he soon turned
into public enemy number one for the
british who wanted him dead
and buried they even tasked one of their
best scouts american officer frederick
russell burnham to track down and kill
fritz burnham failed to do so and later
described his experience in his memoirs
he said there were only two men on the
belt i feared and one was to ken much
has been written about to ken most of it
rubbish yet his real accomplishments
were so terrible they make the yellow
journal thrillers about him seem as mild
as radio bedtime stories he was the
greatest scout the buzz produced he was
one of the craftiest men i ever met he
had something of a genius of the apache
for avoiding combat except in his own
terms yet he will be the last man i
should choose to meet in a dark room for
a fight to the finish armed only with
knives around this time we get arguably
the most popular legend which involved
duquesne that of his notorious krug
millions the story goes that the
president of the south african republic
paul kruger had a gigantic horde of gold
shipped out of the capital to a safe
location to avoid having it fall into
british hands with decan in charge of
one of the shipments while passing
through portuguese east africa or
mozambique as we call it today the other
soldiers tried to double-cross again and
steal the gold for themselves the fight
ensued where de ken once again proved
why he deserved his fearsome reputation
he killed them all and had the porters
hide the gold somewhere safe but never
returned to recover it since then the
legend of the kruger millions has spread
far and wide and many people have spent
years searching for this lost treasure
de ken eventually made his way to the
front lines again and took part in the
battle of bergendahl in august 1900.
this ended up being the last pitched
battle of the war even though the
conflict continued for two more years
following another british victory ducan
and his men had to retreat into
mozambique brits was captured again and
sent to an intern camp near lisbon but
just like before this was just a small
detour for him duken escaped again this
time by allegedly seducing the daughter
of one of the guards from this point on
we can honestly say that ken embraced
his new career as a spy and saboteur as
a man with a dozen different identities
who would never go back to the simple
life he once had in the grasslands of
africa
[Music]
after he fled portugal de ken did not
return to south africa instead he did
something incredibly ballsy even for him
he marched straight into the belly of
the beast traveling to england and
joining the british army we're not sure
how exactly he pulled it off but thanks
to his school year spent in britain he
had lost his south african accent and
instead sounded like a posh englishman
some say he simply presented himself as
a bird effector others think that fritz
had fake papers and used them to craft a
new identity for himself but anyway in
1901 de ken returned to cape town this
time as an officer with the british
forces some accounts say that ken used
his british credentials to track down
the location of the concentration camp
where his mother was held he went there
and he found her half dead starving and
infected with syphilis from repeated
sexual assaults he couldn't just walk
her out without raising questions so he
had to leave her behind knowing that he
would never see her again diken
temporarily satiated his lust for
revenge by killing two british captains
that he passed on his way out of the
camp assuming that any of that
actually happened ken then spent some
time building up a network of bur
sympathizers and developing a list of
valuable targets to destroy as much as
he enjoyed spilling british blood he
probably realized that he could do more
damage by blowing up bridges munition
dumps power plants and things like that
however he never acted on his plans
because he was betrayed by one of his
co-conspirators and the entire network
was arrested everybody else was
sentenced to death and executed but
fritz avoided his date with the firing
squad by supplying the english with
secret bower codes for communication
later to ken always insisted that the
codes he provided to the enemy were fake
but for now he found himself imprisoned
in a 17th century dutch ford called the
castle of good hope unsurprisingly he
immediately went to work on his escape
and he intended to dig out the stones
using a spoon his plan was discovered
though so ducan was sent to a penal
colony in bermuda that had been
repurposed as a pow camp for the buzz
this time fritz did not make it out so
easily it wasn't until june 1902 that he
managed to escape the island and secure
passage on a ship with the help of
members from the bar relief committee by
this point the war was over with a
decisive victory for the british but
this did nothing to diminish the hatred
that de ken still felt in his heart
however there was nothing and no body
left for him in south africa so instead
he sailed to america to start a new life
in the u.s de ken landed in maryland and
then made his way to new york city he
still wanted to get revenge on the
british but now that the war had ended
there wasn't much demand for sabotage or
commando work instead he needed to
divide his time and wait for the right
opportunity to come along until then ken
needed a job and found employment with
the new york herald at first he was
simply a bill collector but his
knife-edged stories of hunting and
adventuring out in the wilds of africa
proved popular enough that ken was hired
as a contributing writer he was then
made a regular reporter and by 1906 he
was the sunday editor for the herald
undoubtedly like all other things in his
life deken's exploits out in the world
had been heavily sensationalized but
they found a captive audience which
included one hunting enthusiast named
teddy roosevelt who happened to be
president of the united states at the
time roosevelt's admiration scored to
ken an invitation to the white house in
1909 where the two talked big game
hunting and fritz advised teddy on a
safari that he wanted to undertake so
this is the perfect time to mention the
strangest moment in dekken's career
which for a man like fritz is
really saying something in 1910 he
became one of the driving forces behind
a new movement taking root in america to
introduce the hippopotamus to louisiana
in response to a meat shortage de ken
testified as an expert before the
committee of agriculture and advocated
for the importation not only of the
hippo but also other animals such as the
giraffe the yak the kudu the spring bark
and many others if decent and others had
their way today louisiana would be
teeming with african wildlife and you'd
have to be on the lookout for charging
hippos while fishing in the mississippi
delta and if that's not weird enough one
of the other main proponents of the bill
was frederick russell burnham the same
scout who had once been tasked with
tracking down and killing de ken
unfortunately the build did not pass and
louisiana remained hippo free when he
wasn't writing fritz traveled to war
zones as a correspondent and gave
lectures around the country he married a
woman named alice wartley in 1910 and
became a naturalized american citizen in
1913. the marriage lasted only eight
years but if he wanted deken could have
still built a really nice life for
himself in america if he could just let
go of the past but his hatred still
consumed him so he jumped at the
opportunity to cause more chaos and
suffering to the british provided by the
advent of the first world war
[Music]
we don't know if tiken volunteered or
was recruited but it became a secret
agent for germany during world war one
fritz had no particular ties to the
country prior to the war but going by
the old adage of the enemy of my enemy
as my friend as long as they fought the
british that made them all right in his
book as a bonus slap in the face to
defend the famous british recruitment
posters that showed the mustachioed
officer pointing a finger saying stuff
like your country needs you featured
none other than the country's new war
minister the man again hated more than
any other person on the planet
lord kitchener de ken was mainly active
in south america during world war one
sabotaging ships on their way to britain
he traveled from one country to another
and switched identities often to avoid
detection his basic strategy involved
sending boxes that were allegedly filled
with mineral samples and orchid bulbs
back to england but in reality the boxes
were packed with timed explosives which
were set to detonate during their forage
across the atlantic deken bragged that
he sunk 22 ships using this method and
while he was certainly responsible for
several explosions that number is
impossible to verify his coup de grace
came in february 1916 when de ken set
the ss tennyson on fire by placing on
board a trunk filled with highly
flammable film celluloid plus some
explosives to ignite it adding insult to
injury fritz also tried to make some
extra money on the side by taking out an
insurance policy on the film which was a
valuable commodity back then his brazen
gamble didn't pay off though and he was
discovered when he tried to cash it the
british now put a bounty on his head for
the death of three seamen aboard the
tennyson but de ken tried to evade it by
faking his own death in april 1916
newspapers around the world reported a
story that de ken had been killed while
fighting in bolivia the ruse only lasted
for a few weeks as he was spotted and
recognized but the confusion surrounding
his untimely demise gave the burr
captain enough time to flee south
america and make it to europe we now
arrive at de ken's most boastful but
also most doubtful claim that he was the
one who killed his arch-enemy lord
kitchener we know for a fact that lord
kitchener died on june 5th 1916. he was
one of over 700 people who perished when
the hms hampshire hit a german mine on
its way to russia and sank in the cold
waters off the coast of scotland but
according to ken he was working with the
germans on this hit he said that he was
on board the ship during that fateful
voyage disguised as a russian official
and that he dropped water torches over
the side the german u-boats would know
where to plant the mines he then jumped
overboard into a waiting raft and was
collected by a submarine and taken to
germany where he received the iron cross
no german records survived to verify
this claim so maybe take this one
with a grain of salt whether or not that
happens we can't say for sure but deken
eventually made his way back to america
except that he now styled himself as an
australian veteran named captain claude
strawton he kept the act going for a
while but new york authorities
eventually found out his true identity
and arrested him in late 1917. this
wasn't for any of the bombings or
assassinations mind you after all
america wasn't involved in the war when
any of those took place so they didn't
really care instead ken was indicted on
insurance fraud for trying to claim the
losses he sustained following the
tennyson explosion he was also publicly
outed as a spy as he possessed a letter
from the german consul thanking him for
rendering notable services to our good
german cause as you might imagine the
british really wanted to get their hands
on him and requested to be extradited to
stantral for murder while the whole
process was being worked out de ken
tried a classic strategy feigning
insanity that might work in legal dramas
but it's surprisingly ineffective in
real life and nobody bought it after a
few months he switched up his tactic and
collapsed in the middle of the courtroom
claiming to be paralyzed from the waist
down obviously everybody called
shenanigans but several doctors looked
him over and he passed all of their
examinations he didn't even flinch when
one of them stuck needles under his
toenails ultimately people bought the
ruse and dukeen was sent to the prison
ward of a bellevue hospital what
followed was an oscar-worthy performance
as fritz went full method and spent the
next few months in a wheelchair
pretending to be paralyzed at all times
but sawing through the bars of his cell
whenever he wasn't being watched on may
26 1919 only a few days before his
extradition to britain to stand trial
for murder de ken made his escape
[Music]
following his escape from bellevue fritz
ken remained a free man for the next 13
years this part of his life remains
poorly documented he probably fled to
mexico immediately after leaving the u.s
but we only know of his movements for
sure starting in the late 1920s he
probably should have avoided the united
states altogether given that he was a
wanted man but fritz just couldn't
resist the glitz and glamour of new york
city so he returned under the new
identity of frank to trafford craven he
found a job working for businessman
joseph p kennedy father of the future
president john f kennedy on the
publicity staff of his new production
company rko studios in 1932 ken got
arrested again even though he kept
insisting that he was frank de trafford
craven his arrest was followed by a
prolonged and complicated trial that
involve both the u.s and britain syntax
tradition can often turn into a
bureaucratic nightmare ultimately
britain decided that again just wasn't
worth it so they dropped the request
once again fritz was a free man with no
legal troubles allowed to get on with
his life you'd think that the whole
episode might have encouraged him to
live and let live but not for it to ken
when nazi germany came calling de ken
answered the call in 1937 fritz began
working for the ab there the german
military intelligence service and
started developing a network of spies
you could either obtain valuable secrets
or carry out acts of sabotage all of
this was done with the foresight that
eventually the united states would go to
war against germany by 1939 this network
numbered over 30 people all placed in
key positions around the country and it
became known as the decans spy ring
named after its ringleader however it
did not get a chance to do any serious
harm as the fbi broke up the spy ring
before america even joined the war as it
turned out one of the men inside the
network was not that keen on the nazis
his name was william siebold and even
though he was born in germany he became
a naturalized american citizen and sided
with his adopted homeland he initially
joined the spy ring following pressure
from high-ranking nazi members while on
a trip to germany but once he was back
on american soil he went to the fbi and
told them everything with his
information the authorities arrested
duke and 32 other spies who were later
sentenced to a total of over 300 years
in prison for its tokens days of
adventure chaos and violence were
officially over his trial occurred
shortly after the japanese bomb pearl
harbor so american sentiment was heavily
against traitors duquesne was sentenced
to 18 years in prison and served 12
before being released in 1954. by that
point he was an old broken man in poor
health following a stroke that left him
partly paralyzed he returned to new york
city again or his place in a nursing
home on december 21 1955 de ken gave a
final speech at the adventurers club
even though many members refused to
attend due to his occasional bouts of
treason it proved to be one last chance
for him to reminisce on the bloody and
daring exploits of his youth brits de
ken died of another stroke a few months
later on the 24th of may 1956 age 78
leaving behind a complicated legacy some
people saw him as a brave hero others a
villain and a madman some thought he was
an incredible adventurer while others
decried him as a fraudster and a liar
some considered him a cold-blooded
murderer and others an agent of
righteous vengeance all his life fritz
de ken divided opinions and will
probably continue to do so for the
foreseeable future so i really hope you
found this video interesting if you did
please do hit that thumbs up button
below don't forget to subscribe and as
always
thank you for watching
[Music]
you